the reason why I was number one for 25
years is cuz we have like a 300 people
become millionaires and I ask them 8 now
tell me you become millionaires because
you are smarter than the others people
said no no no no we even get out by the
jobs no matter what the drama is
whatever the external distraction is the
the what's your response to it should be
to double down on the customer
satisfying they're not just satisfied
then delighting them want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey seven Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you as
well you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn some of
the best lessons from billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one be open and vulnerable with
Oprah Winfrey the reason why I was
number one for 25 years is because I
figured out early on there is no story
anybody has ever heard that somebody
else hasn't experienced nothing and I
also figured out probably maybe the
first or second year that all pain is
the same that a mother in Somalia feels
the same way as a weather in Seattle
when she loses her child and the common
denominator in the human experience is
our emotions and our feelings and the
more vulnerable and open you are willing
to be with your story the more actual
understanding you create with other
people and the more powerful you become
people don't think less of you for
sharing your story they think more of
you for having the courage to share it
lesson number two take risks with Elon
Musk he started with a much smaller rod
it's often one
and what's your goal at that point when
you started with fountain one to get to
the point where we had nine it good
night your goal in that life when I
started SpaceX I only thought it goes
maybe at a 10% chance of getting someone
to open side inaudible think that this
would happen this is for sure a dream
come true but I meant anything about
rockets and I was gonna chief engineer
of Space Station since day one and I
don't hear anything that Rockets which
is why the first three rockets males
okay and then so the first three valve
in one's perspective failures yes and
then tell me about the fourth one so I
had actually only had that funny with
free delivery flights so I had no money
left
the team sort of rallied and we put
together enough spare parts to create a
fourth launch and that fourth loss was
successful and and you know what what
would have happen if it wasn't
successful oh well we were SpaceX for
the night so we would not be here right
now at this moment getting ready to
launch fruit dragon to the Internet is
lesson number three delight the
customers with Jeff Bezos we haven't had
any existential crisis
knock on wood if I don't want to jinx
anything but we've had a lot of kind of
dramatic events I remember there early
on we only had a hundred and twenty five
employees when Barnes and Noble who the
big you at united states bookseller
opened their online website to compete
against us Barnes and noble.com we'd had
about a two year window we opened in 95
they opened in 97 and at that time all
of the headlines and the funniest were
about how we were about to be destroyed
by this much larger company we had 125
employees and 60 million dollars a year
in annual sales
60 million with an M and that and Barnes
and Noble at the time had 30,000
employees and about three billion
dollars in sales so they were giant we
were tiny and we had limited resources
and the the headlines were very negative
about Amazon and the one that's most
minimal our memorable was just Amazon
toast and and so I called it All Hands
meeting which was not hard to do with
just 125 people we got in a room and
because it was so scary for all of us
this idea that now we finally had a big
competitor that literally everybody's
parents were calling and saying you know
are you ok is the figure it's usually
the moms calling and asking their
children are you gonna be ok so and I
said look you know it it's okay to be
afraid but don't be afraid of our
competitors because they're never going
to send us any money
be afraid of our customers and if we
just stay focused on them and in in in
instead of obsessing over this big
competitor that we just got that will be
fine
and I really do believe that I think
that if you stay focused then the more
drama there is and everything else no
matter what the drama is whatever the
external distraction is the the what's
your response to it should be to double
down on the customer satisfying them not
just satisfied then delighting them also
if you want to have more confidence and
self-love check out my to 54 series
they're free the link to join under
description below you really have to
believe the Internet's going to be
mainstream a lot of people are gonna get
out there and use it become so skilled
so vigilant so flat-out fantastic at
what you do that your talent cannot be
dismissed it's so difficult to be a
small business owner in China it took me
five months to warm 500 RS lesson number
four get used to being rejected Jack Ma
our first IP year's year 2007 when
Alibaba IPO in Hong Kong year 2007 we
had a lot of millionaires in the company
and I asked my friend my colleagues
alike we have like a 300 people become
millionaires and I asked them eh now
tell me you become millionaires because
you are smarter than the others the
people said no no no no we even cannot
find the jobs because you are
hardworking yes we were happy we found
more people hard-working than us but
they did not succeed one of why they're
not smart all the smart people at that
time they went to Microsoft and IBM and
headhunting companies came to head and
all the best guy from us and we are the
people nobody kept a head on us
we have no place to go we believe in
ourself we believe our dream will work
together so I say we are the people
because nobody want us I am the person
over 30 companies don't want me right so
we are the people get used to be
rejected where the people get used to be
say no from the other people why people
should help you people help you that is
unusual people do not help you that is
very common you should work to earn to
be helped
lesson number five invest in what you do
best with Bill Gates you don't see
another business you're not gonna get in
the movie business you're not gonna get
in the banking business you're not gonna
get in the automobile business you're
not gonna go with Warren and getting the
insurance business there's no business
out there that you say this is so
attractive the return is even greater
than it is pouring more money into
Microsoft we're we're a software company
you know what we do well what we love
what we know is building great software
we did make some minority investments in
other companies some Cable other
telecommunications some of those did
okay some did less than okay and so that
was a bit of a lesson to us but we never
took control of anything in that space
because what we know how to manage and
develop and really pursue a vision in is
is strictly software lesson number six
don't dwell on mistakes with Warren
Buffett you haven't bought the stock
your admirer Jeff Bezos that a listing
of the richest people in America came
out he's number one I think your friend
Bill Gates is number two you're number
three so you can see what he's done in
myriad ways now and of course the
question is how come you haven't bought
Amazon is there still time to buy what
you still buy oh I always admired Jeff I
mean I met him 20 years ago or so and
and I thought he was something special
but I didn't realize you could go from
books to it what's happened there no I
mean he had a vision and executed and
away something that it would not have
you know that but there's a lot of games
I miss I would have missed you know I
would have missed Microsoft even if I
got into no bill early or something
those just aren't my games I don't worry
about the things that MIT I miss that
are outside my circle of competence of
evaluating I I do I have missed things
who are within my circle and that's a
terrible mistake
those are my biggest mistakes you
haven't seen them and but I don't it's
not a mistake because I miss Netscape or
something like that at all there's I
would say that maybe 5% of the companies
or 10% of the companies that most are
within an area my circle of competence
there's something I should be able to
understand unless the number seven the
last one before a very special bonus
lesson is build a team with Mark
Zuckerberg you're building Facebook I
mean there have been lots of challenges
and they're all these times where in
anything you do where you know you're
really gonna be pushed and you feel like
you want to give up or something like
that and you know this gets back to it
was talking a second ago about how I
think the media there's a little bit of
this cultural bias towards thinking that
you know one person does this right I
mean people say that you know I built
Facebook or Steve Jobs built Apple or
whatever but you know that's really not
true right I mean it's we're more people
we we helped but there were thousands
and thousands of other people involved
in building these things and the reality
is is that as strong as any one
individual is no one person can deal
with all the challenges that are gonna
get thrown at them and in anything that
you do and one of the ways that I think
we maintain resilience is by having
co-founders and partners who complement
our strengths and fortify our weaknesses
and can kind of encourage us and give us
a push to to keep going when things are
tough and there's actually a lot of data
on this that suggests that companies
that get started with more co-founders
are more likely to be successful and it
isn't quite clear exactly from that data
why that's the case although it is very
clear in terms of the outcome for the
startup is that it is the case but I
would guess that the reason why that's
the case
is because of this resilience point
where people who start something by
themselves I just think like there's no
way that any one person can overcome all
of the different things that you need to
do to build a startup or take on any
kind of other project in the world but
if you have two or three or four
partners then I don't know I mean maybe
over time
one of them doesn't like it and drops
out but you still have enough strength
on the team to power through all the
challenges that you have and that's kind
of how you go now have a special bonus
lesson from Mark Cuban on how to fight
for opportunities that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one who's the next person that you need
to bring on your team number two what's
the mistake that you need to stop
dwelling on and number three where do
you need to invest more in what you do
best and if you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believed down the comments as
well I went to Dallas after college cuz
a bunch of my buddies were down there
and I got a job working as a bartender
at night and was looking for a job
during the day and got a job working for
a retail software company and this was
in the early days of PCs and was doing
okay there and then about nine months in
I made em let me add I was living six
guys in a three-bedroom apartment and I
was sleeping on the floor it was the
raddest nastiest hole you've ever seen
in your life I mean and I literally
didn't have a closet didn't have a
drawer all my was in a pile on the floor
I had my one towel that I stole from
Motel six that had a hole in it that was
mine and so I was trying to grind it out
and learn tech which I really realized
that I loved and I made the one day I
called up my boss a guy named Michael
Hume X hu m ec ki and I said Michael
I've got this deal I'm gonna close now
it's $1,500 Commission to me which meant
I can move out of the store and and so I
said I'm one of my responsibilities was
to open up the retail store you know
make sure the door is open the floors
were clean and all that kind of stuff I
said look I've got this big deal I want
to close it and he said no you need to
be
storm-like I got someone to watch
because no you need to be at the store
so I made the executive decision that if
I went and picked up a fifteen thousand
dollar check for this company your
business software he would see the light
and all would be good and I'd have my
fifteen hundred dollar Commission fired
my ass seriously Michael human since
then one time one time literally after
broadcast comm one public he sent me a
letter asking if I was interested his
company you should bring him on Shark
Tank anyway so that was the only time
I've talked to Michael he Mickey and so
and so he fired me and so there was
still who this whole with my one Motel
six towel and bedrooms and so it was
then that we started Michael solutions
and I had no money and so I went to this
company called architectural lighting
and I said look I got nothing but I know
you were trying to you want this time in
billing software if you front me the
$500 I'm gonna start this company and I
promise you that I'll make it work and
if I can't make it work a walk your dog
I'll wash you know your car I'll do
whatever to make it up to you just trust
me and give me the shot they did I took
that five hundred dollars but that spent
two hundred fifty dollars on the
software got that to work really fast
and then ask for referrals and built
this company that then went on to become
one of the first companies that did
local area network this was the early
80s and then went wide area networks and
as you said we sold it to CompuServe and
along the way I kept on reinvesting and
one day I went to the ATM and I had all
zeros you know it which was not fun but
like you said we ended up building it we
had thirty six million dollar revenue
run rate and sold it to CompuServe which
was part of H&R Block and you know all
was in alignment again and it wasn't
like I started thinking okay if I fail I
don't care it was purely out of
necessity I didn't know what else to do
if you want to know more lessons from
successful billionaires check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there and I'm gonna tell
you something that a lot of people 99%
of people disagree with me on it wasn't
as though in creating these companies
that we thought that we would be
successful